let's bring in skies alex rossi now who
is in zaparisia we were just bringing
you those pictures of that coach
arriving a hundred or so people leaving
mariappol on sunday they have arrived
safely there alex what can you tell
us well i can tell you it's been an
extremely long journey and a difficult
journey for these people to get here uh
you can see that uh there are a number
of coaches here they arrived here a few
minutes ago this is the reception center
in zapposia organized by the united
nations here they'll be registered and
then hopefully they'll find places to
stay
after this we can see people over here
they are still
some of them on the coaches getting off
but
what a traumatic time these people have
had they've been inside the as of style
steelworks in some cases since the
invasion started so
more than two months they've been uh
living underground under constant
bombardment
there are a network of tunnels under
this soviet era steel works
which has provided sanctuary but as the
course of the war as the course of the
invasion has gone on
it has or is turning into a tomb many of
the families
that have gathered here waiting for
these people didn't think they would
ever
see this day
but it's here some of these people have
managed to escape you can see
on that woman's face she is relieved but
um
a terrible time really a really really
difficult time there are of course fears
really there are a number of people
still trapped inside we think at least a
couple of hundred civilians uh there are
also fighters as well
uh from the ukraine military
the fear is they won't be able to get
out we are hearing uh reports that that
steelworks is now under constant
shelling again the fragile ceasefire
which started
this mission started on friday got some
people out on saturday and then into uh
sunday and now now we're here quite a
long time afterwards but the ceasefire
has broken down now
so it isn't clear whether you'll be able
to get more people out now arriving here
as well over the last uh day or so last
24 hours they've also been people who've
as a result of the ceasefire being able
to get out of the city of mariopol
and they are bringing with them some
really terrible stories of atrocities
and terror inside that city
much of it has been
destroyed uh it's really destroyed
obliterated beyond recognition
in many places i was speaking to one
woman who was telling me that in the
neighborhood she lived in
you'd have apartment blocks and then
between those apartment blocks there
would be cemeteries where uh people
would have to bury their neighbors
because they'd been killed in the uh in
the fighting so an extremely difficult
time uh for the people of mariopol but
there are still lots of people in the
city not just in as of style the city's
population before the war was about 450
000
possibly a bit more
we think there's about 100 000 people
left in the city
but extraordinarily difficult
for those people that remain
and alex what happens to them now
they've been through so much to get
there we can see them talking to various
people around them obviously there's
media there that want to hear their
stories but where do they go
next
well i think in
in many cases they'll go and stay with
friends and families
family others will head abroad and
become as five million people have in
this country they will become uh
refugees you can see these people
getting off now they've got some of
their things with them
but they'll be heading over here we'll
just move the camera around now and i'll
show you you can see in the background
uh you can see a tent over there that
will be a registration uh point where
their details will be taken by
uh the un they'll also be given if they
need it some medical treatment there
as well and they can be given
homes within ukraine as well but i think
lots of people it's quite an unnerving
experience for lots of these people
because they will be arriving here but
they won't really in some cases be
knowing where exactly they are going at
this point
so not only have they they had to deal
with the trauma of leaving mario paul
and the steel works in some cases i
should point out that some of the people
on this coach have been picked up on the
way in the city as a result of the
ceasefire not everybody that we're
seeing here has been trapped inside the
as of style steel works
but they also now of course have the
unknown in some cases of where exactly
they will be staying but you can see
that there is a huge amount of interest
in this story uh press from all over the
world i mean the world's attention
really has been for the last few months
on the city of mariopol and also of
course on that steel work where people
are trapped in inside and we've seen
we've seen some terrible
pictures from inside that place that
have been posted on social media
civilians fighters
uh in dire need of emergency medical
treatment people who've lost limbs uh
people with wounds that are gangrenous
and have gone septic
and of course they're not getting the
attention and the aid they need they
need but here
we are seeing some people who've
have managed to get out so
in terms of ukraine
this is being seen
in many places really as a symbol
of hope in what has been a really dark
uh period
for the country
but lots of people getting off some of
them fairly unsteady on their feet
uncertain of course i mean it must be
quite disorientating
the time they've had remember of course
that the journey for these people if
they have left the as of store steel
works would have started on saturday we
saw pictures of people coming out of the
rubble
extremely dangerous remember they were
only able to get out because there was
this uh temporary ceasefire and we've
seen and they will have known know this
too we've seen these ceasefires break
down all the time so you'll be coming
out of the steel works not knowing of
course if the fighting is going to start
again
then they went on buses and moved to
russian speaking uh occupied ukraine in
a place called benzemann where there was
a camp where they were processed one
woman told me
that while she was there she had her
possessions searched she was also had to
answer lots and lots of questions uh the
russians of course want to make sure
they don't they're not prepared to let
any of the fighters uh leave she had her
phone uh searched for for pictures
as well then
they had to get to this point here about
16 to 20 checkpoints
at times they were turned back and it
wasn't certain it certainly wasn't clear
yesterday because we were here all day
yesterday waiting for these people to
arrive it wasn't clear whether they'd
make it at all it might the agreement
that has allowed this to happen it was
feared it could break down we just see
some more people moving out now
we'll just walk over and show you inside
the tent as well this is uh if we go
over here
through these people here i mean
huge amounts it's a woman there's a
woman woman here
who you see
and
she has been she is overcome with
emotion a young baby she has in her arms
i don't know what her story is but
everybody here
has a story
of absolute horror and absolute
terror uh one woman i was speaking to
yesterday who managed to get out of
mario pool showed me some pictures on
her phone
and the entire neighborhood where she
lived had been destroyed
the place was just
unrecognizable you couldn't tell that it
was the city now at the beginning of the
war
i was in mariopol
and it was a prosperous city
uh it was really you know an economic
success story within ukraine but it has
been completely destroyed now the reason
behind that
uh in terms of the strategy of the
russians
is that they want to build a land bridge
to crimea
uh which they managed to
capture and then annex in 2014
and
also establish supply routes to bolster
their invading force across the south
and east of the country they're trying
to take the donbass region in eastern
ukraine at the moment but you can see
the people here i mean
the expressions on their faces
of relief but you can also see
the pain
of what the last couple of months have
been i mean it's been
absolutely horrendous
really really difficult time but
that journey is now
at an end or one phase of that journey
is at an end but inside those steel
works i think everybody i don't i mean
we don't everybody can remember what
those pictures
have been like absolutely horrendous
near constant bombardment not just from
the shelling but also from the air as
well another person i spoke to told me
about
the the nature of the explosions they
learned to pick them up after a while
the shelling they could cope with but
the big bunker buster bombs
they didn't know whether
the area that they were in which they
had felt safe in
would just
simply collapse they just didn't know
whether they would get out
alive at all but you can see here
a hundred or so people have managed to
escape
relief
but also pain
and absolutely terrible memories
of what they have been through